I need you to stay quiet this is a me
thing it is not a we thing you got that
fine but make it quick
open on five one of I think our great
hopes for future films is other
articulations of venom symbiote
as fans the comics will know Carnage is the
bond between Cletus Kasady
and the red symbiote and so this
movie will introduce Cletus Kasady hi
Eddie
carnage is the promise of the venom
character taken to the next level so you
know going into venom you were hoping
that there'd be carnage and they
delivered in a very delightful way that
made you go alright I'll give you more
of my money if you do this again
welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have a whole bunch of new venom carnage
and spider-man stuff to talk about
they're currently filming venom 2
right now Tom Hardy's been posting some previews from behind the scenes so we'll
break it all down there's also news
about what's going on with spider-man if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
going to be a lot of spider-man stuff
happening next year and we're doing a
Marvel giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
best spider-man venom theory on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this so obviously in that clip
they're just talking about setting up
the carnage character at the end of the
venom movie just teasing a big venom
versus carnage fight it started out as a
pretty simple concept but now it's
become a much bigger thing because of
all the Marvel and Sony stuff that
happened this past summer so for a
little while we all saw spider-man left
the MCU Tom Holland says that he got
really drunk at a pub got on the phone
with Bob Iger Disney CEO and cried about
bringing spider-man back to the MCU and
doing right by the fans Bob Iger gets on
the phone with a Sony president and they
fix everything
spider-man is back in the MCU with a
brand new sharing deal I'll play that
clip of Tom Holland talking about
getting drunk on the phone with Bob Iger
in a second hands down best way to bring
spider-man back into the MCU just get
rip-roaring drunk while you're talking
to one of the most powerful people in
the entertainment industry but the thing
that everybody had really been hoping
for this entire time is to finally see
spider-man show up in a movie with venom see them cross over even if he's not
going to wear the symbiote right away just to see them together on screen would be
amazing before all the drama
it didn't seem like that was going to be
realistic but now because of their new
sharing deal between Marvel and Sony it
actually seems like they are planning on
doing that way faster than we ever saw
so right now the venom 2 movie has been
shooting scenes that will be set in
around New York City the movie itself is
filming in London but they're making
some scenes that they're filming right
now look like they're being shot in New
York City there's a couple big Easter
eggs and the stuff that they're doing
I'll explain that in a second but this
is that funny clip of Tom Holland
talking about getting drunk to save
spider-man I don't know we had a really
good plan with what we were going to do
with Sony the future of spider-man was
still very bright
but it would have been a shame to take
him out the MCU you know where he
belongs and we've built such a strong
character in that world and it would
have been a shame to lose that but I'm
just really glad that we...I'm really
glad you got drunk and got on the phone
with Bob and then my family and I went
to the pub quiz and I get a phone call
from an unknown number and I'm have a
feeling, I think this is Bob Iger
but I'm drunk and then he said there is
a world in where we can make this work
and then there was a bunch of phone
calls back and forth from Tom Rothman
he was really instrumental in the
process and and and it was really
interesting for me to have these two
studio heads ask, what do you think
well Bob's I think... Bob said you cried on
the phone is that true?
you did you really I didn't we I did you
did a little bit
one of spider-man's finest saves
although I would not recommend getting
drunk on the phone with people that hold
the power over your contract so the
really cool stuff that's happening right
now on the venom set is that they're
filming scenes at the same Estes home
for boys
most of you longtime spider-man comic
book fans and carnage fans will
recognize that that is the orphanage
where Cletus Kasady was raised as a boy
so presumably there's either going to be a
flashback there or they'll have an
action scene there said in present day
and they're setting things in and around
New York City they're slowly moving the
venom character into the periphery of
where spider-man is remember what he
said during that venom carnage
post-credit scene when I get out of here
there's going to be carnage so in the
comics after Cletus Kasady got the
carnage symbiote one of the first things
he did when he went on his rampage was
destroy that orphanage if you haven't
heard anything about the Morbius movie
this sony is doing - it's sort of a
venom spin-off movie with Jared Leto
playing the Morbius character from the
comics that movie is also supposed to
take place in and around New York City
so you could see that Sony was already
sort of intending on setting their venom
verse in and around
city it only made sense that eventually
you would start to see spider-man show
up in those films tonight we had a
really good plan with what we were going to do with Sony the future of spider-man was
still very bright whatever their
long-term plan was before the Sony
Marvel drama originally people assumed
that we wouldn't see spider-man show up
with venom in one of those movies like
maximum carnage eventually for a long
long time but that might be happening
way faster now because of the terms of
their new sharing deal between Marvel
and Sony spider-man has two more MCU
movies now including spider-man 3
that'll be inside the MCU and then
there'll be a crossover movie during
Marvel phase 4 that they haven't
announced yet just mystery movie
speculate all you want about what that's
going to be but right after the
powers-that-be confirmed this spider-man
was back in the MCU a little while ago
Tom Hardy separately posted this picture
of himself to his Instagram wearing a
spider-man iron spider costume so one is
kind of funny to see him do that but -
this was also happening while they were
ramping up to hire Andy Serkis and start
shooting the venom sequel so you have
all this spider-man and venom stuff
happening behind the scenes and suddenly
venom himself Tom Hardy is running
around inside an MCU costume earlier
this year while Kevin Feige was doing
press for spider-man far from home
before all the drama started he was
asked point-blank if Sony was going to use
Tom Hollands spider-man in their venom
movies and he said yes probably but that
would be their deal and he wouldn't have
much involvement in it at the time most
of us just assumed that that meant he
was trying to say that venom would not
be part of the MCU so any spider-man
venom crossover would be sort of a
separate thing and they wouldn't
consider a cannon to the Marvel movies
he later changed his comments after the
spider-man drama when they signed that
new sharing deal his direct quote now
and this was published in deadline read
spider-man is now the only character who
can travel between cinematic universes
which is a joke about the Marvel MCU
multiverse and the way they intend on
handling spider-man jumping back and
forth between venom movies and MCU
movies and if that doesn't get you more
excited he was at Brazil Comic Con just
a couple weeks ago talking about Marvel
phase four he said that the multiverse
would be the future of the MCU
over the next several years their next
big story device that they're using the
way that all the Hollywood news trades
were explaining Marvel and Sony's
crossover plan for spider-man and venom
they called it a call and answer system
where spider
would appear with venom in a venom movie
at some point Sony is allowed to
reference the events of the MCU
spider-man movies as much as they want
like Mysterio the vulture Avengers
endgame the snap him dying coming back
to life big things like that then after
that venom crossover movie this Sony
does when spider-man comes back into
another MCU movie again
Marvel is allowed to reference the stuff
that happened to him in that venom
crossover but from what they're saying
Tom Hardy himself won't jump back and
forth between MC movies and Sony venom movies it'll just be Tom Holland jumping
back and forth between universes and
they'll treat it like a multiverse story
like the venom movies are happening in
an alternate universe Tom Holland
already confirmed that there was a plan
for something like this in spider-man
into the spider burst he was going to
record scenes as if it was his version
of MCU spider-man appearing in a
crossover in that film they went up
scrapping that plan at the last minute
but it just lets you know that that's
already how they were intending on
handling crossover oh it's all part of
this giant multiverse right now as far
as what the Sony people in the Marvel
people have said venom 2 is just them
doing the carnage origin story and venom
versus carnage with a couple lesser side
characters thrown in like they added the
shriek character as Cletus Kasady's
girlfriend before he becomes carnage but
if Tom Hardy himself is teasing a little
bit of MCU spider-man just having some
fun with the fans in some of venom 2
will take place in and around New York
City early prediction they start
referencing actual Tom Hollands
spider-man at some point during that
film either in a post-credits scene or
in the background of one of the scenes
in New York like on a newspaper the
other really cool rumor that's going
around too is that Sony intends on using
J jonah Jameson the new version that
appeared at the end of spider-man far
from home is this sort of thread through
the Sony in the Marvel films I'll do
more venom and spider-man videos as we start to learn more about what's going
on with the next movie but leave your
requests in the comments below
congratulations David Patriots you're
the giveaway winner for my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details everyone click here for
that spider-man into the spider verse 2 teaser trailer
and click here for my new
Mandalorian episode 6 video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!